finally we need to get the client to ask
for the right image to be downloaded
that is it needs to know what device
pixel ratio the device is using and
potentially the layout size too if it's
responsive to layout width and then
request only the appropriate image
this last part is the hard part because
the web browser tries to kick off image
downloads as early as possible which of
course is a good thing for getting
content on the screen quickly but bad if
the client asks for more than one
version particularly on a mobile device
with limited bandwidth
so how do you think we should approach
this problem of asking for the right
image at the right time